obviously I'm not saying blatantly
disrespect your woman she's your woman
she's your queen she's the most
important thing in the world to you she
needs to be retreated in a way that she
feels that it's unfortunate because I
keep tying back to this Baseline point
but the reason I keep going back to this
Baseline point is to try and explain to
everybody at home how simple world the
world can be if you go back to the
baselines of it why do men cheat most
women don't know you'll see them all the
time why do men cheat all because manage
is stupid and why do men [ __ ] girls
uglier than their main chick why do men
do all this stuff you know why I'll tell
you why let's go back to the first thing
I've been saying this whole time status
yeah that's my chick she's home took
this one home yeah I got that one she's
chasing me status but it's but it's
stupid to females I get it but that's
the male world because sexual access is
an easy indicator of status so that's
one of the reasons they do it right so
you have to go back into the Baseline of
white men even cheat in the first place
I'm telling you if you're a woman the
smartest thing you can do is look after
your man make him not want to cheat be
perfect but there's going to be a time
across a 20-year marriage you might just
need to be a little bit blind